[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute mal nicht aus der Küche,
aber dennoch ein sehr gefragtes Video.
Ich zeige euch heute, wie ich meine Wäsche wasche.
[Applaus]
Irgendwie klingt das ein bisschen banal,
wenn ich das so sage,
aber immer wenn ich Storys gemacht habe,
kamen von euch ganz viele Fragen.
Die habe ich gesammelt.
Ich zeige euch heute zum einen,
wie so meine Waschroutine ist,
und zum anderen, was ihr eben beachten müsst
bei der Waschmaschine, beim Textilsortieren,
beim Waschmittelaussuchen oder auch beim Weichspüler.
Also Wäscheroutine.
Ich kann euch jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich täglich wasche
oder einmal die Woche oder zweimal die Woche.
Da müsst ihr natürlich auch selber gucken, wie euer Bedarf ist.
Wir sind ja mittlerweile ein Vier-Personen-Haushalt.
Am Anfang waren wir zwei Personen, Murat und ich.
Und da hat es auch einmal die Woche ausgereicht.
Ich hatte auch noch eine andere Waschmaschine
und wir hatten einfach eine andere Routine.
Mittlerweile gucke ich einfach immer so je nach Bedarf.
Mal haben wir mehr Wäsche, mal weniger.
Mal wasche ich täglich,
manchmal auch nur einmal die Woche.
Da guckt ihr einfach selber.
Was ich aber am allerwichtigsten finde, ist:
Wo ist denn euer Waschraum überhaupt?
Wenn ihr nämlich jetzt gerade noch beim Bau seid
oder plant, irgendwann zu bauen,
oder ein Haus kauft und grundsaniert
oder vielleicht in eurer Wohnung
alles ein bisschen umgestalten könnt,
finde ich es am allerallerbesten,
dass die Waschmaschine nicht im Keller steht,
wo sie bei 80% der Menschen steht,
sondern dort, wo die Wäsche anfällt.
Ich meine, früher hat man das schon so gemacht,
dass die Waschmaschine im Keller verschwunden ist.
Waschmaschine und Trockner waren aber auch sehr laut früher.
Also es war wirklich ein Hubschraubergeräusch
und man wollte eben
dieses Geräusch nicht in der Wohnung haben.
Es hatte natürlich auch platztechnische Probleme
und dann hat man immer unten alles verstaut.
Aber mittlerweile denke ich einfach,
für mich im Alltag ist es einfach sehr unlogisch,
wenn die Waschmaschine im Keller ist,
ich aber im zweiten Obergeschoss bin
und dort mein Schlafzimmer habe, mich dort umziehe,
die Wäsche dort entsteht.
Denn man spart sich einfach ganz, ganz viele Laufwege.
In unserer alten Wohnung war es so, da hatten wir
– also in der ersten Wohnung war es so,
da hatten wir die Waschmaschine einfach im Badezimmer drin.
War ganz praktisch.
Das war auch Samiras Wickelkommode sozusagen
und ich habe da einfach die Auflage gehabt.
Dort hatte ich natürlich ein bisschen wenig Platz.
Und in unserer letzten Wohnung,
die wir eben vor diesem Haus hatten,
war es so, dass die Waschmaschine im Keller war.
Und für mich als Frau war es dann immer extrem schwierig,
– nicht, weil ich schwach bin,
sondern, weil einfach die Wäsche sehr schwer ist –
die Wäsche vom dritten Obergeschoss,
also von der Dachwohnung,
in den Keller runterzutragen,
die nasse Wäsche, die ja dann noch mehr wiegt,
wieder nach oben zu tragen.
Und deswegen habe ich gesagt:
"Wenn wir ein Haus bauen, dann ist der Waschraum hier oben
direkt neben dem Schlafzimmer,
wo einfach jeder ganz kurze Laufwege hat."
Und deswegen ist hier unser Hauswirtschaftsraum.
Also ich habe zwei Hauswirtschaftsräume.
Der eine ist unten.
Das ist mehr so der Vorratsraum bei der Küche.
Und der andere ist eben hier oben.
Und ihr seht auch schon,
es ist ein sehr kleiner Raum.
Aber der hat es echt in sich.
Also da ist wirklich alles richtig praktisch und funktional.
Ich zeige euch gleich noch ein bisschen mehr dazu.
Aber zuerst einmal
gehen wir jetzt wirklich ans Wäschewaschen.
Und bevor man die Wäsche richtig waschen kann,
sollte man sie zum einen richtig sortieren.
Ja, als Murat und ich am Anfang zusammengezogen sind,
da habe ich mir natürlich
noch nicht so viele Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Das war ja auch mein erster Haushalt.
Und wir hatten am Anfang eine Wäschetonne.
Da haben wir praktisch die ganze Wäsche drin gesammelt.
Und Ende der Woche
– freitags immer war das meistens –
musste ich dann natürlich die Wäsche sortieren,
damit ich die Wäsche richtig waschen konnte.
Und das ist dann immer ausgeartet.
Denn dann habe ich alles in der Badewanne sortiert.
Da hatte ich so einen Hügel mit weißer Wäsche,
einen Hügel mit bunter Wäsche,
einen Hügel Handtücher und Buntwäsche und so weiter.
Murat hat sich natürlich immer tierisch darüber aufgeregt,
weil ich freitags dann nicht alles geschafft habe.
Und das ging dann...
Ja, du musstest es halt immer ausräumen
zum Baden oder zum Duschen.
Und dann habe ich gelernt und habe gesagt:
"Okay, wir machen uns drei Wäschetonnen."
Das heißt, wir hatten dann schon drei,
eine für weiß, eine für bunt, eine für dunkel.
War jetzt auch nicht so ideal.
Weil du musstest dann praktisch jedes Mal
Deckel hoch, Wäsche rein.
Und dann habe ich gesagt:
"Wenn wir irgendwann einen Waschraum haben,
dann möchte ich Einwurfschächte haben.
Viele haben ja auch so einen Wäscheeinwurfschacht,
der dann praktisch in den Keller führt.
Das vielleicht noch ganz kurz zum Ort des Waschraums.
Natürlich ist es nicht möglich
oder nicht immer möglich, den Waschraum dort zu haben,
wo man ihn eben haben möchte.
Und viele haben ihn eben im Keller.
Und dann kann man sich wirklich
so einen Wäscheschacht machen,
wo die Wäsche runtergeschmissen wird und dort landet.
Aber, wie gesagt, hochtragen muss man sie dann trotzdem.
Hier habe ich jetzt endlich einen Schrank.
Und da war es mir auch ganz wichtig,
dass der wirklich hier vorne diese Öffnungen hat
und ich einfach die Wäsche hier reinschmeißen kann.
Ich sortiere meine Wäsche in schwarze,
dunkelbunte,
hellbunte
und weiße Wäsche
und habe dann noch vier weitere Fächer
und zwar helle Handtücher,
dunkle Handtücher,
Putztücher und Handwäsche.
Wir haben jetzt hier das System von Schüller.
Schüller baut nicht nur Küchen,
sondern eben auch Waschräume, Hauswirtschaftsräume.
"Easy & Clean" heißen die.
Und da kann man sich wirklich
alles wunderbar zusammenstellen lassen und planen.
Und es ist einfach superfunktional und praktisch.
Und die gibt es auch in jedem Küchenfachgeschäft.
Also dort könnt ihr gern mal schauen.
Und ich habe das jetzt hier so gemacht,
dass ich hier einfach diesen einen Schrank habe,
diese Einwurfschächte habe.
Und da drinnen
sind nämlich auch schon direkt die Wäschekörbe dazu.
Und diese passenden Wäschekörbe, die sind da drin.
Das heißt, man kommt dann her
und schmeißt die Wäsche rein.
Ich habe es jetzt hier beschriftet.
Ich wollte ursprünglich so bunte Schrift,
damit Samira und Ela auch ohne zu lesen wissen,
was reinkommt.
Aber die zwei beziehungsweise Ela
kommt sowieso nur hier unten dran.
Und da habe ich es dann einfach so gemacht,
dass schwarze Wäsche hier oben ist.
Das heißt, da kommen eh nur Murat und ich dran.
Und Samira und Ela, die haben meist gar nichts Schwarzes.
Hier habe ich dann dunkle bunte Wäsche.
Da kommt die Samira schon ganz gut dran.
Und Ela legt es mir einfach auf den Boden.
Hier unten helle bunte Wäsche
und ganz unten weiß.
Das sind so die, die wir auch am meisten brauchen.
Und schwarz braucht der Murat am meisten.
Und da hat man einfach wirklich den Vorteil,
ihr schmeißt die schmutzige Wäsche rein,
man muss sie nicht mehr anfassen,
man muss nicht mehr in der dreckigen Wäsche herumwühlen
und hat einfach direkt alles sortiert
und wirklich einen Arbeitsgang weniger
und einfach ganz, ganz viel Zeitersparnis.
Ich muss immer wieder kontrollieren,
ob nicht doch was Falsches wo gelandet ist.
Aber das sehe ich dann spätestens dann,
wenn eben die Wäsche dann zur Waschmaschine geht.
Ja, beim Wäschetrennen ist einfach nur wichtig,
dass ihr wisst: Was gibt es für Textilien?
Das heißt, die Textilien solltet ihr schon ganz gut kennen
und das Etikett innen lesen.
Und da sind ja auch die Wäschesymbole.
Und da sortiert man einfach so,
dass man nach dem Empfindlichsten geht.
Das heißt, wenn ihr zum Beispiel Sportkleidung habt,
die aus synthetischen Stoffen besteht,
dann solltet ihr die nicht unbedingt bei 60°C waschen.
Schaut einfach auf die Wäschesymbole.
Vielleicht können wir da auch
einfach kurz auf ein paar eingehen.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal hier ein Kleid raus.
Das ist noch ganz neu.
Ich habe es jetzt auch auf links gedreht.
Und dann habt ihr hier immer das Etikett,
wo immer ziemlich viel draufsteht.
Und
hier habe ich sogar noch einen Knopf.
Guckt mal. Beim Knopf mache ich es so.
Das ist ja sowieso das zweite Etikett.
Das schneide ich dann meist weg.
Da ist ja auch oft ein Scherensymbol.
Und damit ich den Ersatzknopf nicht verliere,
habe ich natürlich
– natürlich! –
hier hinten so ein Gefäß
Und da sammle ich alles.
Da kommt der Knopf rein.
– zack –
und Nähzeug.
Und wenn ich dann mal einen verliere,
kann ich ihn wieder drannähen.
Guckt mal. Hier steht sogar schon: "Wash inside out",
also auf links waschen.
Das heißt, einfach einmal umdrehen,
dass die Farbe innen ist und das Innenteil außen.
Das besteht jetzt zu 100% aus Viskose.
Und jetzt habe ich hier die einzelnen Symbole
und die sind meist auf jedem Textil wirklich vorhanden.
Also hier vorne ist so eine Wäschebottich.
Da steht immer drin, dass man es waschen kann.
Dann auch, wie viel Grad,
30, 60, 40, 90.
Und wenn da so ein Strich drunter ist, dann bedeutet das
einfach Pflegewaschgang in der Waschmaschine.
Dann habe ich hier noch das Dreiecksymbol.
Dieses bedeutet: Bleichen beziehungsweise nicht bleichen.
Das Viereck mit dem Kreis bedeutet: Trockner.
Bei mir ist jetzt der Trockner durchgestrichen.
Aber es gibt auch beim Trockner Unterschiede.
Da gibt es dann eben
gut trocknen und heiß trocknen
oder eben auch schonend trocknen.
Das steht dann da eben auch mit drauf.
Dann gibt es ein Symbol,
was viele wahrscheinlich nicht kennen,
und zwar das Viereck mit dem Strich drinnen.
Das bedeutet nämlich
– also ich habe jetzt hier einen vertikalen Strich.
Das bedeutet, ich kann das Kleid später nach dem Waschen
– ich darf es ja nicht trocknen,
aber ich kann es hängend sozusagen trocknen.
Und dann gibt es auch welche mit horizontalen Strichen.
Das bedeutet wie zum Beispiel bei Wollpullovern,
dass man die einfach liegend tropfnass trocknet,
damit die sich eben beim Trocknen nicht aushängen.
Das ist auch ganz wichtig zu wissen.
Ich darf mein Kleid auch bügeln.
Da ist auch das Bügelsymbol.
Da sind dann auch immer ein Punkt,
zwei Punkte oder drei Punkte mit dabei.
Und dieses Symbol hier bedeutet: Nicht chemisch reinigen.
Hat aber eigentlich auch für zu Hause jetzt keine Bedeutung.
Denn das wäre sowieso in einer Textilwäscherei
oder eben an einer Reinigungsstelle.
So. Das sind die einzelnen Symbole.
Da solltet ihr wirklich darauf achten.
Und natürlich hat man ja nicht immer Kleidungsstücke,
die einwandfrei, optimal zusammenpassen.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier dieses Kleid,
dann habe ich aber vielleicht auch ein Baumwolloberteil,
eine Sportbekleidung.
Und beim Sortieren achtet ihr einfach darauf.
Schaut so gut wie möglich,
dass die Textilien einigermaßen zusammenpassen,
auch farblich natürlich.
Und wenn ich dann aber Textilien habe
wie zum Beispiel eine feine Bluse oder einen BH,
die wasche ich natürlich nicht einfach so mit,
sondern habe einfach einen Korb für Handwäsche.
Die sammle ich hier drin.
Und dann passiert da wirklich auch nichts.
So.
Dann geht es jetzt eigentlich direkt an das Wäschewaschen.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr ein Programm auswählt,
was dann wirklich für die Textilien gedacht ist,
die am empfindlichsten sind.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier mein Viskosekleid habe
und aber auch noch was aus Baumwolle drin habe,
– Baumwolle verträgt etwas mehr Temperatur,
Viskose eben jetzt nicht so stark und eher Pflegeleicht –
dann nehme ich eben doch die Pflegeleicht-Stufe,
damit wirklich nichts kaputtgeht.
Los geht's! Oder?
Wir waschen jetzt!
Ich habe hier unten so eine Schublade
und da kann ich jetzt den Wäschekorb draufstellen.
Und wir haben hier einfach darauf geachtet,
dass die Waschmaschine und der Trockner,
weil ich eben viel Wäsche wasche,
auf Augenhöhe sind.
Das heißt, ich muss mich einfach nicht komplett runterbücken.
Unter der Waschmaschine habe ich noch eine Schublade.
Zeige ich euch gleich.
Und ich glaube, eine der häufigsten Fragen ist:
Wie voll darf die Waschmaschine sein?
Wie voll darf man sie beladen?
Und da müsst ihr wirklich darauf achten,
dass sie nicht zu voll ist.
Also früher hat man echt oft gesagt:
"Wenn sie nicht voll ist, dann lohnt sich das Waschen nicht."
Da ging es natürlich auch um Wasser, Strom
und eben auch Waschmittel.
Es ist aber leider so, dass,
wenn die Waschmaschine zu voll ist,
fehlt ja auch die Mechanik.
Das heißt, die Textilien können ja nicht gut schwimmen,
das Waschpulver oder Waschmittel verteilt sich nicht gut,
ihr könnt Rückstände davon haben,
Flecken davon bekommen
und das Wasser kann eben auch nicht alles schön ausspülen.
Das heißt, ich belade das jetzt hier mal
und achte natürlich auch noch mal auf die Textilien.
Das passt auch.
Und das ist jetzt so die dunkle Buntwäsche.
Normalerweise, wenn ich ganz viele Sachen habe,
teile ich noch zwischen blauer und grüner Wäsche
und roter Wäsche.
Aber, weil ich jetzt einfach nicht so viel habe, passt das hier.
Jetzt hat sich da noch ein Handtuch mit reinverirrt.
Das kommt aber hier oben rein,
Handtücher dunkel.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach wirklich
noch ganz gut Platz hier in der Waschmaschine.
Es könnte auch noch was reinpassen.
Wir haben auch ein große Waschmaschine.
Ich sehe das auch hier, weil hier dransteht:
"Bitte Wäsche einlegen, maximal 9 kg."
Das heißt, ich habe eine Waschmaschine,
die eben auch die Beladungsmenge erkennt,
die die Textilart erkennt
und den Verschmutzungsgrad.
Eigentlich muss man da fast gar nichts mehr alleine machen.
Aber ihr könnt auch einfach als Faustregel schauen:
Wenn eure Hand oben als Faust noch ganz gut reinpasst,
dann ist es okay,
dann solltet ihr nicht mehr Wäsche reingeben.
Und ich kann die Waschmaschine jetzt hier
– die ist jetzt so etwa
so drei viertel beladen.
Ist jetzt aber auch okay,
weil ich, wie gesagt, eine Automatik-Waschmaschine habe.
Und die nimmt dann eben entsprechend weniger Wasser,
entsprechend weniger Waschmittel.
Und dadurch ist es dann wirklich okay.
Ich habe jetzt hier bunt gemischte Textilien drin,
das heißt Feines, Pflegeleichtes, aber auch so Karohemden,
die jetzt nicht so ganz fein sind.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt aber ein Pflegeprogramm wählen.
Und ich zeige das euch jetzt mal einmal,
wie man es macht, wenn man es manuell macht.
Und zwar nehmt ihr euch euer Waschmittel.
Da solltet ihr unbedingt darauf achten,
dass ihr ein Waschmittel verwendet,
was zum einen hautfreundlich ist,
vielleicht keine Duft- und Farbstoffe drin hat.
Weil zum einen landen die alle in der Umwelt,
zum anderen auf der Haut.
Und ich bin auch nicht perfekt.
Ich versuche jetzt wirklich überall nach und nach zu schauen,
dass ich wirklich umsteigen kann
und vieles ersetzen kann.
Es gibt auch Waschnüsse.
Es gibt auch Kastanienwaschmittel.
Also ich bin mir da selber
gerade noch ein bisschen am Einlesen.
Und ich habe jetzt hier eins,
was zum einen weniger Plastik hat,
weil es eben keine Flasche ist,
und zum anderen ist es auch vegan.
Weil, was in Flüssigwaschmittel und Weichspülern drin ist,
will man oft eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Schlachtabfälle sind oft mit drin.
Rindertalg ist mit drin.
Und ich glaube, darauf will man in seiner Wäsche zumindest
auf jeden Fall verzichten.
Ich habe jetzt hier eins, was auch die Ela ganz gut verträgt.
Und ihr achtet jetzt darauf
je nachdem, welche Wäsche ihr drin habt
und wie viel ihr drin habt.
Dann habt ihr auf der Rückseite bei jedem Waschmittel immer
einfach die Anwendung.
Verschmutzungsgrad,
ihr habt die Wasserhärte
und ihr habt natürlich die Wäsche.
Das heißt, wenn ihr keine Waschmaschine habt
mit einem Automatikprogramm,
wo einfach die Waschmaschine
selber das Waschmittel dosiert,
dann achtet bitte auf die Rückseite,
verwendet nicht zu viel Waschmittel.
Denn das Problem ist, es wird dadurch nicht sauberer,
sondern das Waschmittel verfängt sich in euren Textilien
und gerade später, wenn es dann im Trockner landet,
kann es sogar passieren,
dass ihr dadurch noch mehr Flecken habt als vorher.
Also wirklich immer gut dosieren
und nicht überdosieren!
Spart etwas Geld,
spart etwas Umweltverschmutzung
und natürlich ist es ganz hautfreundlich.
Wenn ich starke Verschmutzungen habe,
dann probiere ich es mit Gallseife.
Die wird einfach aufgebürstet,
dann lasse ich es einwirken
und dann kommt es ganz regulär mit in die Wäsche.
[Musik]
Ich habe das jetzt hier so,
dass ich einmal nur mein Waschmittel auffüllen muss.
Man hat ja in seiner Waschmaschine
einmal ein Fach für Waschmittel,
einmal für Weichspüler
und hier hat es noch ein drittes Fach
eben für manuelle Wäsche.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt hier
die Waschmaschine mit i-DOS.
Das heißt, die Waschmaschine erkennt von ganz alleine
die Beladungsmenge, die Textilart
und den Verschmutzungsgrad.
Und ich muss nur einmal mein Waschmittel,
mein Flüssigwaschmittel auffüllen
und die Waschmaschine dosiert es dann von ganz alleine,
sie zieht sich Wasser von ganz alleine
und wählt eben auch das Programm von ganz alleine.
Was ich hier noch dazu sagen kann,
wie gesagt, ich habe ja hier drei Kammern
und die Waschmittelkammer hat
1,3 Liter Fassungsvermögen.
Das heißt, man füllt es wirklich nur einmal auf
und hat dann einfach
30 Waschgänge lang ungefähr wirklich die Ruhe
und muss nichts mehr auffüllen.
Ich habe hier noch den Weichspüler.
Und warum wir keinen Weichspüler benutzen,
hat wirklich verschiedene Faktoren.
Zum einen kann man sich wirklich einen Haufen Geld sparen.
Zum anderen ist ja der Weichspüler dafür da,
um die Wäsche weich zu machen.
Die Wäsche wird hart durch den Waschvorgang,
weil zum Beispiel das Wasser zu hart ist.
Wenn ihr aber zu hartes, kalkiges Wasser habt,
könnt ihr entweder Essig mit dazu geben,
Essigessenz oder etwas Natron
oder ihr könnt ganz einfach eine BWT-Anlage,
also eine Enthärtungsanlage verwenden,
die sowieso ganz gut ist.
Denn so bleiben eure Rohre, eure Waschmaschinen
und die Geschirrspülmaschine einfach auch verschont
und sie leben eben auch viel länger.
Der Weichspüler ist ja was,
was nach dem Waschvorgang,
also nach dem Ausspülen einfach noch mal
in die Wäschetrommel mit reingespült wird
und sich dann um die Textilfasern legt.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen, was dann passiert.
Der Weichspüler landet zum einen eben auch in der Umwelt,
also im Abflusswasser,
er landet aber auch auf eurer Haut.
Und jemand, der wirklich empfindlich ist,
– wie meine Ela zum Beispiel –
die merken das eben auch sofort.
Also ganz viele Hautausschläge,
ganz viele Hautreizungen, trockene Haut und Neurodermitis
entstehen dadurch, dass man einfach Weichspüler verwendet.
Was dadurch auch entsteht,
ist Gestank in der Waschmaschine.
Denn normalerweise reinigt sich ja die Waschmaschine
während dem Ausspülen,
aber wenn ihr Weichspüler benutzt,
dann bleiben die Reste eben auch in der Waschmaschine
und dadurch kann es eben passieren,
dass sich Bakterien ansammeln,
die Waschmaschine stinkt
und dadurch eben auch die Wäsche,
wenn sie mal eine Stunde drin liegt,
eben auch schon muffig riecht.
Und dann beginnt der Teufelskreis.
Denn muffige Waschmaschine,
macht man noch mehr Weichspüler rein
und das endet im Prinzip nie.
Weichspüler legt sich eben um die Textilfasern
und verändert aber auch dann die Eigenschaft eurer Textilien,
also, wenn ihr Sportbekleidung zum Beispiel habt.
Und die soll ja atmungsaktiv sein und den Schweiß
und die Feuchtigkeit vom Körper nach außen tragen.
Kann sie dann nicht mehr machen,
weil sich eben der Weichspüler um die Fasern legt.
Das heißt, ihr schwitzt noch mehr in eurer Kleidung.
Wolle und Seide wird zum Beispiel schmierig.
Frotteehandtücher, die saugen keine Feuchtigkeit mehr auf
oder auch Geschirrhandtücher.
Und Dinge wie Elastan oder auch Jeans,
die beulen sich einfach schneller aus,
weil der Weichspüler das Elastan mit angreift.
Und so, wie ich vorhin kurz erwähnt habe,
sind einfach oft Schlachtabfälle
im Weichspüler mit dabei.
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt vorstellt,
der Weichspüler, der wäscht sich nicht aus der Wäsche raus,
sondern bleibt als letzte Schicht auf den Textilien,
dann landet das ganze auf eurer Kleidung
und im Endeffekt auf eurer Haut.
Und ich glaube, auch gerade der Umwelt-, der Haut-
und der Kostenfaktor sind wirklich Gründe,
warum man einfach keine Weichspüler verwenden sollte.
So viel zum Weichspüler.
Und man kann ja auch seine Wäsche
wieder weich bekommen, indem man einen Trockner benutzt
oder eben ein Bügeleisen.
Da kommen wir später dazu.
Wie gesagt,
ich habe bei mir mein Waschmittel schon aufgefüllt.
Das reicht mir jetzt auch noch.
Ich bekomme das auch angezeigt.
Ansonsten rechnet ihr euch jetzt einfach aus.
Die meisten Waschmittelhersteller liefern ja auch
so einen kleinen Becher mit dazu
und da könnt ihr dann euer Waschmittel einfüllen.
Ich habe ein Waschmittel für Buntes.
Das geht dann für so 20°C bis 60°C-Wäsche.
Ein Waschmittel für Weißwäsche ist auch empfehlenswert,
weil da einfach Bleichmittel drin sind,
die eben eure weiße Wäsche auch weiß bleiben lassen.
Und wenn ihr braucht,
könnt ihr euch noch ein Feinwaschmittel holen
für Wolle, Seide.
Und wenn nicht, dann braucht ihr das eben nicht.
Ich achte einfach immer drauf,
dass nicht so viele Duft- und Farbstoffe drin sind,
weil eben das für die Haut jetzt nicht ganz so gut ist.
Okay. Ich habe jetzt hier meine Wäsche drin
und würde jetzt im Normalfall
einfach hier Stufe Pflegeleicht wählen.
Ich kann euch ja mal kurz hier die ganzen Stufen zeigen.
Hier habe ich mein Baumwollprogramm
für Handtücher oder auch für Bettwäsche zum Beispiel.
Baumwolle Eco bedeutet einfach etwas energieschonender
und wassersparender, dauert aber ein bisschen länger.
Pflegeleicht eben für pflegeleichte Textilien.
Und wenn mal etwas nicht so schmutzig ist,
dann einfach hier Schnell/Mix.
Hier habe ich noch Seide und Wolle
und auch noch weitere Programme,
die ich individuell einstellen kann.
Hier auf der linken Seite habe ich dann
ein Extrapogramm für Hemden und Blusen,
ein Extra-Kurz-Programm,
wenn es mal richtig schnell gehen muss,
AllergiePlus,
Sportswear,
Pflegeleicht Plus
oder eben die beiden Automatik-Programme
sanft und intensiv.
Ich nehme jetzt hier Automatik sanft,
weil die Waschmaschine dann eben Textilart erkennt,
Wasser und eben auch Waschmittel richtig dosiert.
Sonst verplappere ich mich jetzt zu sehr
und wir kommen gar nicht mehr zum Wäschewaschen.
Und in der Zeit kann ich schon mal
meine Handtücher abhängen.
Ich mache auch alles immer ziemlich parallel
oder putze in der Zeit das Bad.
Die Handtücher hatte ich gestern Abend schon gemacht
und habe sie dann auch angetrocknet,
also auf bügeltrocken,
und hänge sie dann aber gern noch mal auf,
damit sie schön glatt sind.
Denn dann habe ich einfach einen schönen Schrank
und glatte Handtücher.
[Musik]
Jetzt bringe ich kurz die Handtücher weg
und dann zeige ich euch noch kurz den Raum.
[Musik]
Wenn man hier reinkommt,
dann habe ich hier eben, wie gesagt,
Waschmaschine und Trockner, beides erhöht,
und eben auch hier mit der Schublade
für den Wäschekorb,
dass ich den eben schön ablegen kann.
Darunter habe ich dann jeweils eine Schublade.
Hier rechts verstauen wir Toilettenpapier.
Ist gerade ein bisschen knapp,
aber wir kaufen das jetzt wieder nach.
Und hier links habe ich das Gleiche.
Darüber habe ich dann auch Fächer,
habe hier diese Körbe reingestellt.
Hier sortiere ich zum einen noch
Handtücher hell und Handtücher dunkel.
Da oben habe ich einfach noch so Tragetaschen.
Weil irgendwie kommt es immer vor,
dass ich hier oben eine Tasche brauche, eine Tüte,
und dann habe ich nichts.
Also habe ich irgendwann eingeführt,
ich habe hier Tragetaschen.
Die Schränke habe ich bis komplett oben gebaut
und auch planen lassen.
Ich komme da auch so dran
– wenn nicht, habe ich auch einen Hocker
für den Murat –
und habe hier einfach noch Staufläche.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen,
dass ich da oben noch gar nichts drin habe
außer in zwei, drei Schränken.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht,
irgendwann kriegt man das Haus immer voll
und Stauraum kann man immer brauchen
und bevor da oben der Schrank zustaubt,
mache ich lieber Fächer hin,
die verschlossen sind.
Und da kann man zum Beispiel Bettwäsche lagern,
Winterbettwäsche, die man im Sommer nicht braucht,
oder Sommerbettwäsche, die man im Winter nicht braucht,
oder Jacken, die man nicht anzieht.
Also ich denke, Stauraum ist eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Zwischen den beiden Maschinen habe ich hier ein Fach,
das ich wirklich sehr liebe.
Denn hier oben habe ich eine Stange,
wo ich dann eben auch nasse Wäsche trocknen kann.
Hier dieses Fach zum Herausziehen.
Und da kann ich euch gleich,
wenn wir dann auch was aufhängen, was dazu sagen.
Hier unten habe ich immer noch Körbe,
weil man die auch immer ganz gut brauchen kann
zum Waswegbringen oder Mitherholen.
Hier oben habe ich dann auch eben, wie gesagt, den Schrank.
Dann habe ich hier das Fach für Putztücher und Handwäsche,
also für die schmutzige Wäsche.
Hier verstaue ich meinen Waschmittelvorrat.
Und das ist auch wirklich ganz gut.
Denn so kann man Waschmittel
einfach auch im Angebot kaufe, kann es lagern,
einmal in die Waschmaschine einfüllen und fertig.
Und hier habe ich tatsächlich einen Korb, der einfach leer ist.
Man braucht auch leere Flächen.
Denn voll kriegt man sie immer.
Hier unten habe ich dann noch
unsere Fußmatten mit drin.
Das ist hier auch ganz praktisch.
Und hier war so ein kleines Zwischenfach.
Und das ist ja oft so ein toter Raum.
Aber der ist hier gar nicht tot.
Denn hier habe ich einfach ein Handtuch drin.
Wenn ich hier nämlich Hände gewaschen habe,
kann ich mir hier die Hände abtrocknen.
Und da ist wirklich jeder Platz richtig gut durchdacht.
Dann geht es hier hinten weiter.
Hier links von der Waschmaschine
habe ich offene Regale gewählt.
Denn alles, was offen ist, ist natürlich auch schnell greifbar.
Das heißt, ich muss nicht noch mal extra einen Schrank öffnen.
Und das Ganze ist so ein bisschen nach hinten versetzt.
Also, selbst wenn es da mal unordentlich wäre,
sieht man es eben nicht auf den ersten Blick.
Aber ihr kennt mich.
Ich muss immer alles beschriften und etikettieren,
damit jeder weiß, wo alles steht.
Und hier habe ich einfach die Dinge,
die ich zum einen für die Waschmaschine
oder für den Trockner brauche
oder auch am Waschbecken.
Also hier einfach so ein Fach für Wäsche.
Das heißt, ich habe hier meine Gallseife,
mit der ich eben Flecken behandle.
Gerade, wenn jetzt die Kinder essen und trinken und spielen
oder auch ich mal Make-up-Flecken
auf meinen Oberteilen habe,
dann nehme ich einfach Gallseife.
Hier habe ich noch ein Fach für Spüli und Essig,
weil die auch bei mir regelmäßig im Gebrauch sind.
Hier meine selbstgemachten Reiniger wie der WC-Reiniger
oder ich habe auch Natron und Zitronensäure immer da.
Hier Handseife zum Auffüllen
und Handschuhe und Schwämme.
Und auch da oben habe ich wieder Schränke zum Verstauen.
Aber die sind auch bei mir momentan leer.
Was ich hier noch im Hintergrund habe?
Hier im Hintergrund habe ich eine Organisationswand.
Und da habe ich zum einen meine Küchenrolle
oder auch eine Schere, Schwämme,
meine Wäschekörbe.
Und die Organisationswand, die ist echt praktisch.
Denn hier kann ich alles hin- und herschieben.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier zwar die Küchenrolle,
aber wenn man die nicht braucht,
kann man auch was anderes hinhängen.
Und da habe ich einfach in jeder Ecke
noch meine Steckdosenleiste,
hier unten meine Wäscheklammern
und hier vorne auf diesem kleinen Haken
noch meine Spülschwämme und Spülbürsten.
Dann habe ich hier vor dem Fenster
einfach noch mein Waschbecken,
was ich auch sehr wichtig finde in einem Waschraum.
Denn man hat zum einen die Trocknerflüssigkeit,
man hat aber auch mal was zum Vorwaschen
oder zum Behandeln, zum Händewaschen.
Und es ist ja auch der Ort,
an dem ich eben meine Putzsachen aufbewahre,
um das Obergeschoss zu putzen.
Also bei uns ein Waschbecken ganz wichtig.
Falls ihr euch wundert:
Wie klappt das mit dem Waschbecken
und der Armatur und dem Fenster?
Man kann es umknicken.
Ja.
Denn wir haben es hingeplant und dann dachten wir: "Ups!"
Aber es gibt zum Glück welche,
die man einfach umknicken kann.
Hier unten habe ich einfach auch noch Platz und Stauraum.
Hier drüben ein Auszug für Müll.
Ich habe hier einfach auch einen Müllbehälter.
Und dann sind wir im Prinzip schon auf dieser Seite.
Und da verstauen wir alles,
was wir an Kosmetik und so weiter für uns brauchen.
Also habe ich hier einen geschlossenen Hochschrank,
weil ich da einfach nicht so oft dran muss.
Und ich will einfach auch da keine Unordnung sehen.
Also hier oben habe ich auch alles schön beschriftet.
Das heißt, hier oben ist mein Vorrat.
Dann habe ich noch Sachen wie Sonnenschutz
oder Haarstyling, Haarpflege und Shampoo.
Hier sind Wattepads und Ohrstäbchen drin in kleinen Kisten,
weil es ansonsten wirklich einfach nur herumfallen würde.
Hier noch ein paar Medizinprodukte, alles beschriftet.
Und hier unten einfach alles in durchsichtigen Kisten,
die man auch nach vorne ziehen kann.
Okay, irgendwie fällt mir jetzt auf,
dass Murat nur ein Fach hat.
Aber er darf meine Sachen mitbenutzen.
Und die Kinder sind hier nicht drin.
Die Kinder haben ihren Vorrat in ihrem Bad.
Aber ja, egal, was soll's.
Und er hat ja auch hier seine Zahnbürstenaufsätze.
Okay, das reicht.
Ups!
Was ich hier noch habe, ist zum einen ein Wasserkocher,
den ich auch oft zum Putzen benutze,
weil wir einfach in der Küche
keinen Wasserkocher mehr brauchen.
Induktionskochfeld ist nämlich schneller.
Das heißt, wenn ich Toiletten putze,
habe ich hier immer heißes Wasser,
oder wenn man sich doch mal einen Tee aufgießen möchte
oder was auch immer.
Hier habe ich auch immer Zettel und Stifte,
falls mir was fehlt,
und hier ein Körbchen für Singles,
nämlich für Single-Socken.
Denn es passiert immer, dass Socken verschwinden.
Und die landen dann hier
und wenn sie nach der Wäsche nicht mehr auftauchen,
kann ich sie wegschmeißen.
Denn dann ist das Pärchen
oder der andere verschwunden.
Und ich habe hier noch meinen Selfie-Stick, mein Ministativ.
Denn ich filme hier oft für euch.
Vielleicht, falls man sich wundert:
Warum ist hier ein Selfie-Stick?
Körbchen für Singles.
Was habe ich hier noch?
Ich habe hier eine Schublade.
Das sind die Sachen,
die ich immer in Hotels klaue.
Nein, das sind die Dinge,
die ich aus dem Hotel mitnehme,
die Reisegrößen, die wir natürlich angefangen haben
und aus Gründen der Nachhaltigkeit nicht wegschmeißen.
Das landet dann alles hier,
auch alles schön sortiert.
Das ist so ein Besteckkasten.
Und da sieht man auch,
dass Schüller eben normalerweise auch Küchen macht.
Und ich habe einfach den Besteckkorb genommen
und habe jetzt hier sortiert.
Hier habe ich so Bodylotions.
Und da habe ich Shampoo.
Nee, hier ist Shampoo und Haare.
Hier habe ich so Gesicht.
Hier ist Duschgel.
Und da habe ich alles für Lippen und Zähne.
Dann Make-up-Entferner
und
Vanilleextrakt-Flaschen ausgewaschen,
die eben auch die perfekte Reisegröße sind.
Da könnt ihr euch nämlich Waschmittel abfüllen
oder Deo oder Creme
oder ein Shampoo.
Und das habe ich einfach hier mit drin,
weil ich da Platz hatte.
Hier unten habe ich auch wieder Stauraum.
Da sind jetzt Decken drin, Handtücher und Bettwäsche,
die ich momentan einfach nicht so brauche.
Und im Prinzip bleiben nur noch hier diese großen Schränke.
Hier habe ich ja die Wäscheeinwurfkörbe.
Und hier auf der rechten Seite ist so ein Organisationsschrank,
der echt superpraktisch ist.
Ich habe hier zum einen mein Bügelbrett,
meinen Dampfreiniger,
der auch gleichzeitig mein Bügeleisen ist.
Also das habe ich auch hier.
Und dann einfach auch Putzmittel.
Also ich habe ja gesagt, ich putze ja auch hier oben
– ja, ich putze –
und verstaue hier auch alles.
Also ich habe hier zum einen die Wischmoppaufsätze,
dann noch Zubehör zum Dampfreiniger.
Hier habe ich Reinigungsmittel hinten drin
und vorne dran einfach Putztücher
und genauso auch hier,
damit einfach meine Kinder
– die gehen da zwar nicht dran, aber man weiß ja immer nie.
Und deswegen Putzmittel, Waschmittel,
alles immer oben lagern,
dass die Kinder nicht drankommen.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich einfach Putztücher davor.
Ich komme ja hinten rein,
aber die Kinder,
die sehen das dann eben nicht auf den ersten Blick.
Hier habe ich noch meine Fensterreiniger
und da unten einfach so zwei Reisetaschen,
weil die da perfekt reingepasst haben.
Und so kann ich, wenn ich wirklich mal auf Reisen gehe
und einfach mein Make-up,
meine Sachen, meine Kosmetik brauche,
kann ich mir hier die Reisetaschen nehmen,
meine Reisegrößen einpacken
und bin dann schnell startklar.
Und hier habe ich dann noch so ein freies Fach mit Stangen.
Da kann ich nämlich auch nasse Wäsche aufhängen.
Und da werde ich ganz oft gefragt,
ob denn die nasse Wäsche im Schrank nicht stinkt.
Also ich hänge ja den Schrank dann nicht voll.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt gerade
– so wie jetzt –
eine Wäscheladung wasche,
dann habe ich ja schon mal vier Bereiche,
in denen ich was aufhängen kann.
Hier habe ich noch den Vorteil,
dass ich hier die untere Stange wegnehmen kann.
Also, wenn ich mal lange Kleider habe,
mache ich einfach die Stange kurz weg,
habe dann eben ein langes Fach.
Und ansonsten hänge ich ja wirklich
keine fünf Wäscheladungen direkt hier rein.
Also es trocknet wirklich alles ganz gut.
Aber meistens nutze ich sogar die frische Luft,
gehe nach draußen und hänge da die Wäsche auf.
Und hier verstaue ich eben noch meinen Tritt,
den ich vielleicht mal brauche
oder der Murat.
Und jetzt warten wir kurz auf die erste Wäscheladung
und dann zeige ich euch nämlich,
wie es mit der Wäsche weitergeht.
Denn das richtige Sortieren ist das eine,
das richtige Wasche das andere,
aber nach dem Waschen ist umso wichtiger,
wie man die Wäsche weiterbehandelt,
um dann eben das lästige Bügeln zu sparen,
damit die Wäsche schön glatt wird, gut durchtrocknet
und eben frisch ist.
Also die Wäsche ist gerade fertig.
Aber ich habe jetzt gerade noch
Zuschauerfragen durchgelesen
und die meistgestellte Frage ist zum einen:
Woher ist dein Wäscheaufräumschrank
mit den Wäschekörben?
Habe ich euch ja erklärt, von Schüller.
Und zum anderen wollten einige wissen,
wie groß der Raum hier ist.
Also
ich messe es mal kurz.
2,38 Meter mal
2,73 Meter.
Also 2,38 Meter mal 2,73 Meter ungefähr.
Oh! Sechseinhalb Quadratmeter.
Papa!
Ich drehe gerade!
>> SALLYS PAPA: Was?
>> SALLY: Biz yukarıda çekim yapıyoruz.
Balkonda konuşmak ister misin?
>> SALLYS PAPA: Tamam.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Danke!
Der Papa versteht immer noch nicht,
dass, wenn man telefoniert,
dass man nicht schreien muss bis in die Türkei.
Also ich bin echt gerade beeindruckt.
Sechseinhalb Quadratmeter.
Ich dachte tatsächlich, es sind auch so siebeneinhalb.
Gut, ein Quadratmeter mehr oder weniger.
Aber ich muss halt sagen,
das ist der megafunktionale Raum.
Also auf sechseinhalb Quadratmetern
kann ich hier die ganze Wäsche machen.
So.
Jetzt erst mal Wäscheladung raus.
Es ist nichts mehr drin.
Dann geht es hier direkt weiter.
Und zum Zeitsparen natürlich gleich die nächste Wäsche rein.
Ich nehme
die helle Wäsche.
Aha!
Aha! Haben wir hier was Dunkles entdeckt
und was Weißes.
Und beim Murat muss ich immer gucken,
ob er noch was in seinen Taschen hat.
Also da wäre ich schon längst reich.
So.
Hier bleibe ich auf Automatik sanft.
Wie gesagt, das wäre jetzt auch wieder
so ein Pflegeleicht-Programm 30°C
und mit ein bisschen Waschmittel drinnen.
Im Waschmittelfach,
– das fragen mich auch viele –
da ist ja ein Fach mit einem Strich und zwei Strichen,
also Vorwäsche und Hauptwäsche.
Und wenn ihr keine Vorwäsche habt,
müsst ihr da natürlich auch nichts einfüllen.
Aber es steht auch bei euch an eurer Waschmaschine.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich mache hier meist
immer das Automatik-Programm.
Und jetzt geht es hier rüber.
Jetzt habe ich hier meine gewaschene Wäsche.
Und davon landen ein paar Sachen im Trockner,
aber nicht zum Kompletttrocknen,
sondern nur zum Antrocknen.
Denn, wenn ihr Wäsche antrocknet und sie danach aufhängt,
dann spart ihr euch meistens das Bügeln.
Und ich meine, bügeln gehört jetzt nicht wirklich
zu meinen Hobbys.
Wobei, wenn ich es mache, mache ich es schon gern.
Aber so mich zum Bügeln aufzuraffen, das nicht.
Ich sortiere jetzt mal.
Alles, was ich nicht in den Trockner schmeißen darf,
kommt hier nach links.
Alles, was ein bisschen in den Trockner darf, hier.
Und was ich gerne ganz komplett durchtrockne,
das sind eben Handtücher und Bettwäsche zum Beispiel.
Weil da habe ich einfach den Vorteil, dass
die Handtücher einfach wieder schön weich werden.
Die bleiben dann nicht so dunkel.
So. Meine Karos,
die tue ich auch meist so ein bisschen zumindest
vortrocknen.
Ach, diese ganzen Gürtel immer.
So.
Söckchen.
Und mein Overall, der kommt auch nicht rein.
Okay.
Gut.
Hier beim Trockner habe ich auch das Gleiche.
Also ich habe zum einen diese ganzen Programme.
Wir haben jetzt einen Trockner,
der hier das Wasserfach hat.
Wir haben nicht daran gedacht,
vorher eine Wasserleitung nach außen zu legen
für den Trockner.
Aber, was es auch gibt
– und zwar habe ich das drüben.
Da habe ich nämlich einen Waschtrockner.
Und der benutzt dann praktisch das Trocknerwasser
auch zum Waschen.
Und das ist halt auch echt praktisch.
Aber ich wollte hier zwei Geräte haben,
damit ich eben parallel arbeiten kann.
Und jetzt gehe ich hier eben einfach auf Pflegeleicht
und wähle jetzt hier nicht schranktrocken,
– das ist mir dann zu trocken,
ich will es ja noch hängen –
sondern wirklich nur bügeltrocken.
Knitterschutz gibt es hier auch.
Und was ich bei meinen Waschmaschinen machen kann,
das ist halt echt praktisch bei den Bosch-Geräten.
Ich kann sie mit meiner Home Connect App verbinden
und dann sehe ich eben auf meinem Handy,
wenn die Wäsche fertig ist,
muss ich nicht ständig nachschauen.
Also das ist schon gut.
Und jetzt habe ich hier
sozusagen meine Trocknerwäsche drinnen.
Da habe ich die nächste Wäscheladung zum Waschen drinnen.
Hier habe ich die, die ich gleich aufhänge, drin.
Deswegen habe ich hier immer meine Kleiderbügel.
Und dann spare ich mir auch ganz viel Arbeit.
Ich habe aber auch viel Platz zum aufhängen, muss ich sagen.
Das heißt, da spare ich dann wirklich doppelte Arbeit.
Ich hänge es jetzt hier einmal auf.
Und wenn es später knitterfrei trocknet,
muss ich es nicht mal mehr bügeln.
Guckt mal.
Zack!
Und wenn es doch noch zu bügeln ist,
dann habe ich zumindest nicht mehr so viele große Falten.
[Musik]
Und damit gerade so Kleider wirklich schön trocknen,
achte ich schon immer darauf,
dass hier oben die Naht auf dem Bügel ist.
Ich mache auch die Knöpfe zu.
Dann trocknet es schon mal in die richtige Form.
Und wenn man sich da echt so ein bisschen Mühe gibt,
dann spart man sich im Endeffekt danach viel Arbeit.
Und ich muss sagen, es hat echt was Meditatives.
Also ich mache total gern am Wochenende
oder auch unter der Woche so zum Abschalten die Wäsche,
höre hier meine Musik.
Deswegen gibt es da auch immer viele Videos davon,
in denen ich mich einfach selber filme
und ein bisschen dazu singe und tanze
und euch auch zum Wäschemachen motiviere.
Weil das macht echt Spaß.
Am Ende ist alles schön sauber und ordentlich
und der Schrank hier wieder leer
und der Kleiderschrank wieder voll.
[Musik]
Und meistens gucke ich dann einfach immer schon mal.
Wenn die Wäsche schon schön warm ist,
kann ich sie nämlich direkt rausnehmen
nach dem kurzen Antrocknen.
Guckt mal. Schön durchschwenken und durchschleudern
und dann trocknet sie wirklich superschön glatt
und vor allem ganz schnell.
So spare ich mir ganz viel Zeit
und kann wirklich in kürzester Zeit
ganz viel Wäsche abarbeiten.
[Musik]
Habe ich etwa ein Doppelkinn?
>> JOSH: Nö, gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Nicht? Okay.
Da muss ich die Kleider schon immer schön luftig aufhängen.
Bei Jeanshosen gibt es auch einen guten Trick.
Und zwar wasche ich die ja auch auf links,
dann drehe ich sie danach auf rechts
und damit ich die nicht bügeln muss
und sie trotzdem schön glatt sind,
lege ich sie erst mal zusammen.
>> ELA: Mama.
>> SALLY: Oh, eine Prinzessin.
Hallo!
>> ELA: Hallo! Hallo!
>> SALLY: Kannst du mir später helfen mit der Wäsche?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Riecht gut.
>> SALLY: Riecht gut, gell?
Und dann lege ich die wirklich schön auf ihrer Naht zusammen,.
schön glatt.
>> ELA: Du kannst sie auch
zum Beispiel...
Mama, weißt du, was du auch zum Beispiel kannst?
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Du kannst einfach sie waschen und dann in die...
Und dann...
Und dann in die Spülmaschine tun.
>> SALLY: In die Spülmaschine?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du kleiner Quatschkopf.
>> ELA: Dann trocknen sie.
>> SALLY: Im Trockner, oder?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Oder in der...
Oder...
>> SALLY: In der Spülmaschine wird es auch trocken,
aber nicht so schön glatt.
Und was ich hier jetzt mit der Jeans mache:
Ich lasse die jetzt praktisch hier liegen,
bis ich den Rest eben erledigt habe.
>> ELA: Aber erst mal muss man die auch messen!
>> SALLY: Ja, miss mal. Genau.
>> ELA: Warte. Ich messe und du,
du guckst, okay?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich gucke.
>> ELA: Gleich messe ich.
Ich mache mal schon.
>> SALLY: Ich lasse die jetzt hier praktisch liegen,
bis sie so ein bisschen gesetzt ist.
Und nach so zwei, drei Minuten hänge ich sie dann erst auf.
Und dann sind wirklich schön die Falten geglättet.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Und die Jeans kann dann eben auch gut trocknen.
>> ELA: Ich will dich gerade messen.
>> SALLY: Miss mich mal.
>> ELA: Warte. Stell dich mal gerade hin.
>> SALLY: Ich bin
1,75 Meter.
>> ELA: Ach du meine Güte!
>> SALLY: Ja. Und du? Zeig mal her.
Stell dich mal gerade hin.
Und du bist 1,12 Meter.
Ach du meine Güte!
Ach!
Hast du immer genug getrunken?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Trinkst du mal was?
>> ELA: Ich habe noch gar nichts getrunken
außer bei Oma unten.
So. Und jetzt habe ich schon wieder eine Pause.
Also so mache ich das halt auch echt gerne am Wochenende,
dass ich dann Wäsche reinmache,
dann die Wäsche sofort aufhänge.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Und dann habe ich wieder eine Pause
für die Kinder
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: oder für das Kochen oder Backen.
>> ELA: Wusstest du sogar, dass es jetzt
einen "My Little Pony"-Film gibt?
>> SALLY: Was?
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Gibt es da jetzt einen Film?
Boah!
>> ELA: Darf ich ihn angucken?
>> SALLY: Ja, klar.
>> ELA: Heute?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: Wenn du fertig bist mit der Arbeit?
>> SALLY: Na klar.
>> ELA: Dann können wir bis Nacht warten
und dann gucken wir ihn an als Kinoabend.
>> SALLY: Uh!
Okay, dann machen wir heute einen Kinoabend.
>> ELA: Ja!
Wo ist Samira?
>> SALLY: Die ist, glaube ich, in ihrem Zimmer.
So. Ich bin fertig für jetzt.
>> ELA: Vielleicht hat die heute Morgen...
>> SALLY: Und dann geht es gleich noch mal weiter.
>> ELA: Hast du sie heute Morgen...
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So. Wäscheladung zwei ist jetzt auch fertig.
Und das ist halt echt immer ganz eingespielt.
Das kommt hier rüber.
Dann noch die schwarze Wäsche.
Genug Waschmittel habe ich noch drin.
Auto sanft passt auch.
Und dann kann ich nämlich hier drüben...
Moment.
Die eine Socke noch nachlegen.
Jetzt.
Jetzt kann ich hier drüben
wieder mit der Wäsche weitermachen.
Und hier ist die Wäsche
auch echt schon teilweise gut durchgetrocknet.
Und dann zeige ich euch gleich,
wie es noch mit dem Bügeln weitergeht.
und dann ist die Wäsche schon fertig.
[Musik]
Also hier habe ich jetzt noch eine Wäscheladung,
die ich noch machen müsste,
die weiße.
Die schaffe ich aber auch ohne euch.
Was ich dann noch habe, ist Handwaschprogramm.
Da wähle ich dann hier später
einfach das Handwaschprogramm.
Und gerade, wenn ihr BHs zum Beispiel habt
oder Unterwäsche,
würde ich auf jeden Fall immer so einen Wäschesack nehmen.
Denn die Bügel und auch die Haken,
die können nämlich andere Textilien zerstören.
Das heißt, alles immer schön hier reinpacken.
Wenn ihr Sportschuhe zum Beispiel waschen wollt,
gibt es auch diese Beutel
oder man packt sie einfach
in so einen Kissenbezug zum Beispiel rein.
Und dann schont ihr somit eben auch eure Wäsche.
Das mache ich dann auch später.
Da trenne ich dann auch einfach zwischen den Farben,
weiß und schwarz oder bunt.
Und was ich hier noch habe, sind die Handtücher.
Da habe ich einmal die hellen und die dunklen Handtücher.
Und da nutze ich dann einfach das 60°C-
oder sogar 90°C-Programm.
Und das ist auch wichtig, dass ihr wirklich ab und zu
auch bei hohen Temperaturen wascht,
damit eure Waschmaschine auch schön sauber ist.
Ich habe ja schon gesagt,
unsere Waschmaschine, die stinkt nie,
weil ich zum einen keinen Weichspüler benutze
und weil wir regelmäßig waschen
und ich eben auch mindestens einmal die Woche
die Handtücher einfach bei 60°C oder sogar 90°C wasche.
Und so könnt ihr eben auch die Trommel immer reinigen.
Eine Maschinenpflege ist immer wichtig,
dass ihr auch immer mal die Gummiränder sauber macht,
die Dichtungen,
oder auch hier unten das Fach,
wo einfach eben auch
hier Wasser ausgelassen wird.
Es kann auch mal sein, dass sich da was drin verfängt,
eine Haarspange, ein Haargummi oder eine Socke.
Und das solltet ihr wirklich alles
regelmäßig natürlich auch reinigen.
[Musik]
Die Waschmaschinenpflege ist wichtig,
aber auch die Trocknerpflege.
Das heißt, da regelmäßig Wasser entleeren
und natürlich auch das Flusensieb reinigen.
Der reinigt sich wirklich schön von alleine,
aber ich muss dann einfach
die Flusen aus dem Sieb entfernen,
wieder einsetzen.
Und dann schon ihr eben auch eure Geräte.
Jetzt werde ich hier drinnen alles erst mal laufen lassen
und kann, weil hier alles schon schön trocken ist,
mein Bügelbrett aufklappen
und ein bisschen bügeln.
Wie gesagt, ich mag bügeln nicht so gerne.
Aber ich habe ja jetzt echt fast nichts mehr.
Also ich glaube,
die meisten würden das jetzt gar nicht mehr bügeln.
Ihr seht schon, es ist wirklich schon fast knitterfrei.
Ich gehe da einmal drüber.
Aber so was wie hier mein Overall,
der wird jetzt nicht mehr gebügelt.
Der ist schon glatt genug
und da würde ich eher Falten reinbügeln,
als dass ich sie rausbügle.
Und das ist der einzige Nachteil hier.
Also der Wäscheraum hat sechseinhalb Quadratmeter.
Es hätte aber auch nicht mehr reingepasst,
dass ich praktisch eine Bügelstation habe.
Aber das mache ich dann meist hier einfach vor der Tür,
habe noch so eine Stange daneben
und da kann ich dann die Wäsche schön aufhängen.
Mein Bügeleisen ist jetzt schon bereit.
Hier mache ich gleich weiter.
Und jetzt gibt es hier einfach Sachen,
die muss ich einfach nur dämpfen,
so wie jetzt das Kleid.
Das würde ich jetzt eher zerknittern,
wenn ich es vom Bügel runternehme.
[Musik]
Das ist so schön, wenn dann alles glatt ist.
Dann lasse ich es hier noch kurz so ausdämpfen.
Und dann gibt es Teile so wie dieses Kleid,
das muss ich jetzt schon richtig bügeln.
Übrigens, wenn ich unterwegs bin,
mal in einem Hotel zum Beispiel,
und ich habe kein Bügeleisen,
dann kann man sich so was
einfach in die Dusche mit reinhängen,
da, wo es halt nicht nass wird.
Und wenn ihr dann duscht mit warmem Wasser,
dann glättet der Dampf sozusagen auch euer Oberteil
oder euer Kleid.
Voll der Lifehack für unterwegs.
Und beim Bügeln ist eigentlich nur wichtig,
– also wenn ihr darauf achten wollt –
destilliertes Wasser benutzen für das Bügeleisen.
Schont natürlich das Gerät,
aber schont auch eure Kleidung.
Denn gerade kalkhaltiges Wasser
kann eure Wäsche ein bisschen beflecken,
gibt dann so weiße Rückstände.
Und ich habe am Anfang
auch immer da nicht so wirklich darauf geachtet,
aber irgendwann sieht man dann am Bügeleisen unten
eben schon so eine gelbe Schicht.
Und da spart man sich halt echt Arbeit, Dreck und Kosten
und kaputte Wäsche.
Jetzt bügle ich heute ein bisschen, morgen ein bisschen
und dann habe ich die ganze Wäsche erledigt.
[Musik]
Ich bügle hier jetzt noch ein bisschen fertig.
Die letzte Wäsche,
die ich heute jetzt noch reinschmeißen werde,
ist die Handtuchwäsche.
Die mache ich rein.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass das für heute zu spät wird.
Aber dann kann ich ganz einfach
das Zeitprogramm noch einstellen.
Also, wenn ich weiß,
heute Abend werde ich sie nicht mehr trocknen,
dann wasche ich sie auch nicht mehr,
weil ich sie einfach nicht in der Waschmaschine
liegen lassen will.
Dann mache ich das Zeitprogramm an und kann timen,
dass ich sie morgen früh um acht fertig haben will,
entweder über das Handy
oder einfach über die Waschmaschine.
Die meisten Waschmaschinen haben mittlerweile
auch so ein Zeitprogramm.
Also nutzt es wirklich ganz gerne.
Und ich hoffe, dass ich euch
mit meinem Wäscheroutinevideo ein bisschen helfen konnte,
so ein bisschen Routine zeigen konnte,
wie ich das hier so alles mache.
Und ich muss sagen, Murat und ich,
wir haben uns echt auch ganz gut aufgeteilt.
Also Wäsche ist so mein Part,
damit auch von mir nichts kaputtgewaschen wird.
Denn er trennt nicht so gern die Wäsche.
Und er macht dafür dann eben auch gern mal
die Küche sauber oder die Böden.
Er wischt und saugt immer ganz fleißig.
Das muss ich zum Glück nicht mehr machen.
Und so teilen wir uns alle auf.
Samira und Ela helfen auch ganz fleißig mit.
Also, sobald hier dann alles trocken ist,
hole ich einfach die Kinder her und sage:
"Samira, komm. Hol dir deine Wäsche ab."
Dann holt sie sie ab und kann sie auch wirklich schon schön
in ihrem Kleiderschrank verstauen.
Ich hoffe, euch macht ab sofort das Wäschewaschen,
-sortieren, -legen und -falten genauso viel Spaß wie mir.
Wie gesagt, hört gerne lustige Musik dabei,
schöne Musik, singt und tanzt dabei,
schaut euch meine Storys an
oder lasst einfach das Video parallel laufen.
Denn mit ein bisschen Spaß
macht es wirklich noch mehr Spaß.
Macht das Sinn?
Ach, es macht Sinn.
Egal.
Also mir macht es auf jeden Fall viel Spaß
und ich bin glücklich,
wenn die Wäschekörbe danach wieder frei sind.
Und der Erste, der sich dann traut,
wieder was Schmutziges reinzuschmeißen,
der ist dann schon ziemlich mutig.
Na ja, aber dann jede Woche aufs Neue, oder?
Also viel Spaß beim Putzen,
Waschen, Bügeln, Hängen und Legen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschau!
[Musik]
Ah!
Eigentlich ist ja jetzt mein Waschroutinevideo fertig,
aber ich habe noch einige Fragen gefunden,
die nicht beantwortet wurden.
Die werden wir jetzt zusammen beantworten.
>> MURAT: Ja, weil ich bin der Wäscheexperte.
>> SALLY: Ja, er ist wirklich Wäscheexperte.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Was ist? Gefalle ich dir oder was?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay.
So.
>> SALLY: Also.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Was kann man gegen das Verblassen
von dunklen (Jeans-)Hosen tun?"
Also bei Jeans ist es so...
>> MURAT: Ich würde mir einfach helle kaufen.
Ja, oder?
>> SALLY: Nee, aber oft ist es halt auch bei Jeans so,
wenn man die das erste Mal wäscht,
dann wäscht sich die Farbe raus.
Es gibt ja Textilien, die werden praktisch
– da wird die Faser gefärbt, also das Garn an sich gefärbt.
Und dann gibt es Textilien,
die werden erst gewebt und genäht und werden dann gefärbt.
>> MURAT: Das ist die günstigere Variante übrigens.
>> SALLY: Genau. Und das ist günstiger,
weil man wirklich erst mal alles näht und macht und dann färbt.
Und dann bleichen die halt auch schneller aus.
Also da muss man echt schon auf Qualität achten
und auf hochwertige Textilien.
Und am Anfang ist es ganz normal,
dass Jeans ausbleichen.
Aber später sollte es eigentlich nicht mehr passieren.
>> MURAT: Genau. Wenn da draufsteht:
"Wash with similar colors",
heißt das auf Deutsch:
"Wasche es mit gleichen Farben."
Oder?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: My English was good.
Hauptschule, 9. Klasse, Leistungskurs.
So.
Woher nimmst du die Motivation zum Wäschewaschen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ganz ehrlich, ich finde das so lustig.
Weil irgendwie braucht man immer
eine Motivation für irgendetwas.
Ich meine, die Motivation zum Wäschewaschen
ist eigentlich schon daraus entstanden,
dass, wenn du die Wäsche nicht wäschst,
dass du dann schmutzige Kleidung hast.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und ich will halt...
>> MURAT: Also das ist die Motivation.
>> SALLY: Und ich will halt saubere...
>> MURAT: ... Wäsche haben. So ist es.
>> SALLY: ... gebügelte Wäsche tragen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Ich will ja, wenn ich mich morgens anziehe,
will ich mich frisch fühlen
und da muss halt die Wäsche frisch sein.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und mehr Motivation geht eigentlich gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Außerdem demotiviert es mich,
wenn die Wäschekörbe voll sind.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also mache ich es lieber gleich weg.
"Schaust du bei jedem Stück ins Etikett?"
Das muss ich tatsächlich nicht mehr.
Irgendwann kennt man ja auch seine Wäsche.
Aber bei neuer Wäsche, die ich kaufe,
da schaue ich sogar schon ins Etikett, bevor ich es kaufe.
Denn, wenn auf dem Etikett steht:
"Dieses Kleid darfst du nicht waschen,
sondern nur chemisch reinigen" zum Beispiel,
kaufe ich es erst gar nicht,
vor allem wenn es so ein alltägliches Kleid ist.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und ansonsten achte ich schon sehr auf Textilien.
Und ich kaufe zum Beispiel keine Kleider,
wo ich genau sehe, da ist jetzt Schwarz, Weiß,
Dunkelblau und Violett im Wechsel,
und ich sehe schon, das verwäscht sich
und die Farben bleichen aus.
Dann kaufe ich so was erst gar nicht,
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: weil ich nicht weiß: Ordne ich es jetzt
bei Schwarz ein, bei Weiß, bei Hellblau oder bei Dunkelblau?
>> MURAT: Und meine Sachen sind meistens
schon mehrere Jahre alt.
Nach neun Jahren kennt man das T-Shirt,
das man jeden Tag wäscht, eigentlich schon auswendig.
>> SALLY: "Warum riecht schwarze Wäsche nicht so gut
wie weiße oder bunte?"
Vielleicht liegt es an deinem Waschmittel.
Also ich meine, vielleicht hast du ja
ein anderes Waschmittel für schwarze Wäsche.
Aber ich meine,
die Wäsche riecht doch gleich.
Die Jenny fragt: "Wie waschen sich all die Berge von allein?"
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich mache das.
Ich mache das.
Der Leeroy fragt: "In welches Fach
muss ich das Waschpulver reinschütten?"
>> MURAT: Leeroymatata, das ist eine typische Männerfrage.
>> SALLY: Ja, das wissen viele nicht,
weil da gibt es ja einen Strich und zwei Striche
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: und dann gibt es noch Weichspülerfach.
>> MURAT: Und zwar ein Strich,
man spricht hier von Einbad.
Das ist...
Erzähle ich es?
>> SALLY: Hä? Einbad? Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
>> MURAT: Noch nie? Hast du nie Einbad, Zweibad gehört?
>> SALLY: Nee, ich kenne nur Vorwäsche und Hauptwäsche.
>> MURAT: Okay. Das ist Einbad und Zweibad.
Das ist...
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Das ist ein alter Begriff. Du bist noch zu jung dazu.
Musst du nicht wissen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und da, wo dieses Ding drauf ist,
diese Muschel,
das ist Weichspüler.
Dieses Fach normalerweise nicht benutzen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sarinski fragt: "Wann sehen wir Murat die Wäsche machen?"
Liebe Sarinski, leider sehen wir das gar nicht.
Der Murat darf nicht mehr die Wäsche machen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Seitdem er damals mein Wildlederkleid
bei 60°C gewaschen hat
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und es dann noch in den Trockner geschmissen hat,
habe ich eine Wildledertasche,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: kein Kleid mehr.
Und seitdem darf er keine Wäsche mehr waschen.
>> MURAT: Und ich muss aber ehrlich sagen,
dass ich gern Wäsche wasche,
aber nur meine eigene.
>> SALLY: Ja, er darf.
>> MURAT: Das mache ich.
>> SALLY: Also er darf seine eigene Wäsche waschen,
aber meine darf er nicht mehr anfassen.
>> MURAT: Weil das ist eh immer schwarz oder bunt.
>> SALLY: Ja, und da kannst du nichts falsch machen.
>> MURAT: Da kann ich nichts falsch machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und ich werde sauer, wenn er meine Sachen mitwäscht
und sie dann falsch wäscht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da werde ich echt sauer.
>> MURAT: Darf ich noch einen coolen Tipp geben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Vielleicht wissen das die meisten nicht.
Und zwar: Sneakers werden am besten sauber
in der Spülmaschine.
>> SALLY: Was?!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ehrlich jetzt, ohne Spaß.
Wenn ihr mal Sneakers oder Caps habt,
also das heißt, ihr habt so Mützen,
wo ihr ab und zu mal waschen tut, weil ihr reingeschwitzt habt,
dann tut das in der Spülmaschine machen.
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch!
>> SALLY: Das ist doch voll eklig!
>> MURAT: Wieso nicht? Ich würde schon.
>> SALLY: Hast du das gemacht, als ich weg war?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Ich hoffe, deine Sneaker landen niemals
in unserem Geschirrspüler.
>> MURAT: Wirklich!
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Das bringt wirklich was. Doch.
>> SALLY: Dann nehmt ihr bitte
das Waschprogramm in der Waschmaschine.
>> MURAT: Hört nicht auf sie.
>> SALLY: O mein Gott! Bäh!
>> MURAT: Ich habe es schon probiert.
Nicht bei unserer Waschmaschine
– Spülmaschine, sondern die von den Schwiegereltern.
Ja.
>> SALLY: O Gott!
"Stellst du dein Waschmittel auch selbst her
wie deine anderen Putzmittel?"
Nein.
Also momentan noch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was irgendwann mal ist,
aber momentan habe ich die Zeit auch nicht,
um das jetzt auch noch selber herzustellen.
>> MURAT: Man muss da ehrlich sein.
Man kann nicht immer alles selber machen.
Also wir kochen schon frisch.
Das ist schon mal wichtig.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wir haben Kinder.
Die müssen wir wegbringen
und die müssen wir wieder abholen.
In den Kindergarten zum Beispiel.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem habe ich ja jetzt
ein Waschmittel gefunden, was echt
– womit ich mich ganz gut identifizieren kann.
>> MURAT: Und ich weiß, dass das viele von euch machen.
Finde ich eine coole Geschichte,
wenn ihr die Zeit und die Muse dazu habt.
Aber das kriegen wir noch nicht hin. Also...
>> SALLY: Ah, das ist auch noch gut.
Ich habe es zwar erwähnt, aber vielleicht noch mal.
"Meine Handtücher werden trotz Weichspüler immer hart.
Was mache ich falsch?
Nehme immer Pulvervollwaschmittel für Handtücher.
Einen Trockner besitze ich nicht."
Also zum einen ist es falsch, den Weichspüler zu benutzen.
Denn dadurch werden die Frotteesachen
– können sie keine Feuchtigkeit mehr aufsaugen.
Und der Weichspüler landet eben auch auf deiner Haut
und in der Umwelt.
Zum anderen kannst du einfach
ein bisschen Essig dazugeben oder Natron
nach der
– also bei der Wäsche.
Dadurch wird der Kalk eben auch neutralisiert
und es wird schön weich.
Oder du kannst sogar die Handtücher später
noch mal ein bisschen bügeln.
Dadurch werden sie auch weich.
Und ansonsten, wenn sie dann noch ein bisschen hart sind,
dann hast du halt ein schönes Hautpeeling.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das ist auch immer gut.
>> MURAT: So ist es.
>> SALLY: Ist so.
>> MURAT: Kostenloses Peeling habe ich auch.
>> SALLY: "Bei mir entstehen immer in den T-Shirts Löcher,
obwohl ich sie getrennt wasche.
Hast du einen Tipp dafür?"
Das...
Da habe ich mir auch keine Gedanken darüber gemacht,
aber eine andere Zuschauerin schrieb dann drunter
und das finde ich echt aufschlussreich,
dass zum Beispiel auch so Gürtelschnallen
oder BH-Bügel
oder BH-Häkchen,
die eben auch Löcher
>> MURAT: Nee, da gibt es etwas.
>> SALLY: in andere Wäsche reinmachen können.
>> MURAT: Das müsst ihr wirklich selber googeln.
Da gibt es wirklich was.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: Und zwar ist das T-Shirt immer hier vorne.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das hat aber mit was anderem zu tun.
>> SALLY: Mit den Nähten?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Nee, hat mit was anderes zu tun.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> MURAT: Das ist immer hier vorne,
die Löcher.
Ich kenne die. Da gibt es irgendwas.
Ich habe das mal gegoogelt.
Ich weiß das. Irgendwas war da mal.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Das war es eigentlich.
Oder siehst du noch was?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich sehe nichts mehr.
Ich sehe nur noch dich.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay, wir machen jetzt aus.
Ich glaube, die Fragen, das war es schon.
>> MURAT: Okay. Macht es gut!
Macht es besser!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss! Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Nächstes Mal geht es dann um
Dachrinnen reinigen.
>> SALLY: Geschirrspülmaschine.
>> MURAT: Ja, Dachrinnen, wie die sauber gemacht werden.
>> MURAT: Das mache ich mit einer Leiter.
>> SALLY: Wie Männer
die Geschirrspülmaschine richtig einräumen.
>> MURAT: Ah, ja, stimmt!
Geschirrspüler ist doch auch eine coole Idee.
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich könnte eine Anleitung machen
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: für alle Frauen und Männer.
>> MURAT: Geschirrspüler, genau.
Und da zeige ich euch, wie ich meine Mützen
und meine Schuhe in der Geschirrspülmaschine mache.
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch, das machen wir!
Eine coole Idee, Sally! Machen wir wirklich!
Ich freue mich drauf.
>> SALLY: Oh! Hier, guck mal.
Komm, die letzte Frage:
"Wie oft muss Bettwäsche gewaschen werden?
Da haben wir gestern im Freundeskreis drüber diskutiert.
Wäre alles dabei
– war alles dabei von wöchentlich
bis na ja, dann, wenn es unangenehm riecht."
>> SALLY & MURAT: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Also ich bin da so ein kleiner Monk.
Ich muss die jede Woche waschen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil
>> MURAT: Auch wegen den...
>> SALLY: er schwitzt.
>> MURAT: Wegen den...
Ich schwitze wirklich. Also ehrlich.
Das sind
>> SALLY: Jeder schwitzt nachts.
>> MURAT: Bettwanzen.
>> SALLY: Wäh!
>> MURAT: Ich sage nur: Bettwanzen.
Nee, müsst ihr wirklich, weil ihr habt...
>> SALLY: Das ist voll eklig!
>> MURAT: Hundert Prozent habt ihr in eurem Bett
Hausstaubmilben, Milben.
>> SALLY: Ja, die hat jeder.
>> MURAT: Können wir mal Milben kurz ganz groß?
>> SALLY: Nein! Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch! Mach mal. Josh, mach mal jetzt ganz groß,
wie Milben aussehen.
So. So sehen die Milben aus.
>> SALLY: Jetzt geht jeder seine Bettwäsche abziehen.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt geht ihr alle Bettwäsche waschen, okay?
Weil die sind überall in eurem Bett.
Das garantiere ich euch, egal, wie sauber ihr seid.
Das hat jeder.
Mehr oder weniger.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Tschau!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Ich wollte mit was Positivem abschließen.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Warte. Was Positives.
Mach ein Tierbaby rein, Josh.
>> SALLY: Okay. Tschau!
>> MURAT: So. Tierbaby.
Tschüss!
Macht es gut!
Macht es besser!
[Musik]